leurs maris estelle vous êtes
psychologue qu'est ce qui se passe
pourquoi vous avez tiré la sonnette d'un
parce que ça va intéresser autant les
enfants qui nous regardent les
collégiens lycéens que les parents les
grands parents qu'est ce qui se passe
alors en fait il se passe que moi au
premier confinement comme tout le monde
j'ai pensé qu'il y aurait des stratégies
d'adaptation j'ai plutôt essayé de
rassurer les gens c'était nouveau et
tout le monde a mobilisé des ressources
c'était une épreuve collective et on
pensait que les choses serait réversible
en réalité à partir du mois d'août de
l'année dernière j'ai commencé à
constater avec mes confrères des dégâts
très importants
sur la santé mentale et la santé
physique d'abord des adultes
et puis petit à petit c'est descendu en
tranches d'âge jusqu'à un effondrement à
peu près vers le mois de février on a
constaté vraiment une vague
pédopsychiatrique un effondrement de la
santé mentale et physique des enfants et
même des tout petits ça commençait la
crèche à la crèche vous avez des adultes
masqué donc vous avez des retards de
parole quand vous êtes trop fine et avec
des parents qui vont mal vous avez une
augmentation des risques des violences
domestiques vous ne pouvez pas appeler
au secours vous avez une augmentation ça
aurait créé des choses auxquelles on
pense pas mais quand on les entend ce
deal à moi je me suis retrouvé très
embarrassée parce qu'il se trouve que je
performe consultent pour des cas
d'inceste mais victime d'inceste ce sont
pour certaines retrouver avec leurs
paires qui arrivait à se re confiné en
faisant pitié à la maman qu'est ce que
je faisais avec ces jeunes filles je ne
pouvais pas leur dire d'aller à l'hôtel
ils étaient fermés je ne pouvais pas
leur dire d'aller chez des amis on
n'avait pas le droit donc on a créé en
fait au nom de la santé des situations
qui ont détruit la santé mentale et la
santé physique et qui ont même mis en
danger la vie de nos enfants et de notre
jeunesse moi j'ai la changer des
ressources j'ai accouché de jumeaux
pendant le premier confinement je gérais
pour que j'entendais les femmes
j'entendais les femmes dans les chambres
isolés parfois primipares leur premier
bébé on sait qu'à ce moment là la femme
peut être très vulnérable psychiquement
à la peur de mal faire elle n'avait pas
accès à la nurserie la nuit elle ne
pouvait pas se reposer et le papa
n'était pas là on se rend pas compte
parce qu'on prend des décisions en ce
disant il faut gérer le coc vite donc on
arrête la vie pour éviter la mort par le
commis de concret des dégâts collatéraux
qui sont infinies sur les enfants il
avoue parler que du confinement ça on
n'a pas pu l'éviter quoi vous parlez qui
s'est passé pour le confinement mais
alors un drame le confinement la
déscolarisation puis le couvre-feu
l'arrêt du sport la sédentarité la
malbouffe la pauvreté l'angoissé des
parents donc des enfants qui deviennent
obèses des adolescents qui consomment de
la drogue qui attendent avant toute
chose qui vous dérange aussi c'est
encore le port du masque à l'école
puisqu'elle va nous en parler dans un
instant quand vous entendez marie
estelle vous êtes plutôt d'accord avec
ce qu'elle dit parce que j'ai le souci
que sur un autre plateau on vous dit ça
va il faut arrêter aussi protéger les
enfants c'est pas des enfants rois oui
allez regardez moi avec tout mon respect
madame je suis extrêmement choqué par
vos propos mais nous tous vos propos
c'est quand même vous qui pendant le
premier confinement ou le deuxième avait
dit faites vous des câlins sans masque
depuis le départ vous minimisez
totalement le coc vie de la pandémie est
là vous êtes en train de dire aux
enfants enlevés le match je vous
rappelle juste il suffit de voir les
chiffres qu'au québec en ce moment les
enfants de moins de 10 ans sont les plus
touchés 147 cas par jour donc je vous
trouve à parce que vous avez un
argumentaire très structurée mais sur le
fond c'est irresponsable vous niez la
pandémie et vous allez mettre nos
enfants en danger madame
je ne nie pas du tout la pandémie
monsieur jeudi qu' on n'est pas obligé
de créer de la peur de la
culpabilisation de langoat chez des
enfants aujourd'hui j'ai des petites
filles qui arrivent qui me disent est ce
que je peux toucher le bureau il ya des
germes je vais pas embrasser ma maman
parce que par exemple à son sens riche
parce que je crois qu'il ya pas
pour ou contre il ya le coc vide parmi
les locaux vides n'est pas tout de la
vie et surtout n'est pas tout de la
santé et on peut pas dégrader à l'infini
la santé de nos enfants en espérant
sauver les personnes âgées parce qu'on
n'est pas en train de demander un effort
aux enfants avec le masque on est en
train de leur demander un sacrifice on
peut pas les priver du rapport au visage
humain c'est pas de sport c'est le
masque c'est du distant ciel mais le
cerveau n'est pas fait pour vous c'est
quoi le govic du coup alors oui
proposerait locaux vides je propose
quand même qu'on foute la paix
globalement aux enfants pour qu'on ne
pense pas qu'on ne pense même pas à
fermer les écoles pour une maladie qui
ne concerne pas les enfants
oui pas fermée mais aujourd'hui en faire
un cas
quel sens sa part créé le chaos le
parent il peut pas arrêter de travailler
l'enfant il va se garder tout seul il va
pas apprendre
une chute des résultats scolaires on a
fait hospitaliser encore là une petite
qui se scarifie qu'a laissé des lettres
à ses parents disant qu'elle voulait pas
vivre dans ce monde ont créé du
désespoir on ne peut pas ne pas
l'entendre mais bien sûr puisque à parce
que quand vous entendez sa mine de rien
c'est aussi conduire
mais je l'entends que complètement
d'autant plus que j'ai deux enfants de 5
et 7 ans dont un qui a fait sa rentrée
scolaire en cp dans des conditions le
protocole sanitaire renforcée c'est déjà
en bois sans essai société angoissant
pour lui et donc pour nous aussi
fatalement ce que je comprends et je
vais complètement partager votre analyse
sur le premier confirme enfin le
confinement qu'on a vu qu'il était très
dur très sec et où effectivement mais
pour tout le monde pour nos jeunes aux
plus jeunes pour nous ça a été
extrêmement violent effectivement
l'enjeu de septembre a été de dire
surtout ne revenons pas à ça parce qu'on
a eu des enfants en situation de
détresse vous avez parlé des risques
intra familiaux qui ont été extrêmement
important mais également pour les
personnes âgées qui se retrouver du jour
au lendemain en ehpad sans plus aucune
visite donc oui ça a été dur maintenant
la situation en septembre c'est qu'on
était aussi avec un rebond épidémique
extrêmement violent donc soit on mettait
des protocoles sanitaires forcément on
n'avait pas envie de les avoir en avais
pas envie d'avoir une rentrée scolaire
comme ça mais on les mettait en place
pour permettre la rentrée scolaire soit
on mettait pas en place la rentrée
scolaire l'avez vous rejoindre là je
veux vous rejoindre c'est
qu'effectivement il ya qu à voir dans le
débat par les uns les autres sans
chercher des responsables un espèce de
conflits de générations les jeunes étant
les responsables et mais moi j'ai pas vu
ça personnes âgées les jeunes m'ont dit
la même chose dans mon cabinet ils m'ont
dit pour me protéger pour on me dit que
au nom de ma santé voilà en fait tout ce
que je fais est interdit donc ma vie n'a
plus de sens et ça me le disait quand on
avait 80 ans on me le disais quand on
avait 16 ans on veut me protéger mais en
fait ma vie n'a plus de sens je ne vois
plus personne
guillaume et moi j'entends dj tout à
l'heure en fait ça me fait marrer dans
ton des gens juger des situations qu'eux
mêmes ne connaissent pas et ne vivent
pas s'est retournée là tranquille on est
100 masques ont pu rigoler on peut
respirer etc et on se permet de juger
des enfants qui eux sont doux dans une
période où ils doivent se développer
c'est mon ciré cas des enfants en inde
et en boxe on rentre à l'école ils n'ont
connu club avec le masque et tuba
yamaska la classe par jour et on les
traite d'enfants gâtés n'ont cédé pas
d'allah gâté c'est un ras-le-bol général
ce max c'est une tannée pour tout le
monde nous on a eu la chance d'aller à
l'école sans masque et je pense que
c'est une vraie chance je pense que ce
masque
basket on ne vote pas il faut
les sujets qu'on a à raconter de salades
sur le masque à l'école de toute façon
il le touche il enlève à l'acompte oui
toute façon c'est sale ils émettent
plusieurs fois par jour parce que les
parents ne vont pas acheter de masques
par jour les écoles de l'année valmont
protocole il ya des écoles qui donne des
masques stade il ya beaucoup de choses
qui sont faits par les villes par les
maires donc là je suis pas en train de
défendre juste la majorité volina que
vous apprenez maintenant maintenant ce
qu'il faut aussi voir et peut-être
regarder bien évidemment on aurait
préféré que ça n'existe pas mais ils
vont devoir lever quand c'est moi ça je
suis battu non on peut pas dire qu'on
l'a fait exprès on ne peut pas dire
qu'on a fait exprès parce que ce sont
vraiment les parts on se responsabilise
en tant que l'adulte il a lutté contre
la profitable à la circulation du virus
donc là le virus circule et partout
malheureusement donc il fallait mais où
ils achètent à circuits et moi je pense
qu'on peut avoir un autre mindset est
bien là le ciel vient de signer existe
ce qu'il faut c'est protéger les gens
vulnérables les gens vulnérables on a
bien vu qu'avec les variants et je vous
rejoins si les jaune et d'emmener
vulnérables gens sont les enquêtes avant
mais vu les rabots aussi du jury
twitterers mais tous les maçons du bras
ils vont sur le béton les bains voilà
maintenant ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'il a été annoncé là où et c'est une
bonne semaine et j'espère que ça va
continuer et que les indicateurs
sanitaires étaient plutôt bons et dans
une bonne dynamique donc il ya le sujet
du post sanitaire et j'espère
sincèrement qu'ils auront aussi le sujet
du masque du masque pour nos jeunes du
masque aussi en général en population
générale dehors et aussi pour les plus
les plus petits moi ce qui me pose un
problème c'est le glissement sémantique
qui fait qu'on dit nan mais ils peuvent
quand même faire un effort mais un
effort tel enjeu ce qui a du sens on va
demander un effort supplémentaire aux
étudiants non mais c'est un sacré
l'assise et ne renie leurs besoins
vitaux c'est à dire qu'en fait on est
dans une injonction paradoxale qui fait
beaucoup de dégâts aujourd'hui on s'en
est pas rendu compte parce que au
gouvernement bat vous n'avez pas
forcément fait psycho vous n'allez pas
dans les crèches voilà c'est tout c'est
pas
sur le terrain on voit une injonction
paradoxale c'est à dire que pour être un
bon citoyen tu dois faire tout ce que tu
ne peux plus faire ce que tu dois faire
pour être un adulte tu sors pas de chez
tes parents tu vois pas tes copains tu
pose pas de questions prof tu fais pas
de sport comment ils vont des mois
suivants attendez attendez par contre là
je veux bien mais là ce que vous dites
mais il va falloir faire du sport à
barcelone ça veut dire que nous alors si
vous voulez alors je suis d'accord avec
vous mais c'est pas pour le score le
sport à l'école selon les activités
c'est quand même autre chose si il est
pas d actualité et s'il fallait le foot
il voulait la coi le jardon nouveau à
son nom
colère de la région lanaudière quelque
chose la priorité aujourd'hui c'est de
ne pas retomber dans un confinement on
est d'accord ça c'est la pire des
situations pour la france puis
d'economie tous fermés désintéresser de
ce que je comprends pas c'est qu'est ce
que vous voulez proposer parce que fait
une proposition c
est là aussi vous s'il vous plaît le
masque le masque il sert à rien à
l'école puisqu'il est [ __ ] boudeuse
d'une heure mais c'est vrai
le masque crème beaucoup plus de
problèmes de santé et de troubles de
l'apprentissage qui n'évite de
circulation virale les enfants mettre le
masque et le maître quand même
correctement il faut pas aussi le rwanda
lors un enfant ne se plaint jamais parce
que l'enfant a pour qu'on dit un enfant
ce sur adapte à ce qu'on gagne c'est
parce qu'on est en train de dire mais de
là à dire qu'il faut enlever d'un coup
et d'un seul et même le masque de
manière générale je pense qu'il faut
aussi voir d'où l'on vient et oui
j'espère une ans les semaines qui vont
venir on va pouvoir avoir ses vraies
discussions et enlever le masque pour
les enfants mais de manière plus
générale mais faut pas oublier d'où on
vient le virus circule et de façon
extrêmement importante et la circulation
du virus créé des variants qui ont fait
que ce ne sont plus les personnes
vulnérables algérie qui étaient les
premières victimes de ces représentants
sont ils en danger 62 68 37% vous avez
convaincu les téléspectateurs père se
marie estelle bon prix scarron vous aime
bien quand même voilà mais aujourd'hui
je veux dire nos enfants leur santé
mentale ses terres et maisons des
tickets qu'ils ont des toques ils ont
des phobies ils ont mal au ventre il se
scarifie et j'ai jamais reçu à réaliser
autant pour des troubles alimentaires
waouh mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait notre
futur quoi là on entend les éduquer non
la peur mes lordi au moindre virus vous
vous rendez compte que on a subi une
pandémie oui ce n'était pas de sa vie
récemment pour le plaisir donc il va il
faut quand même réagir et mettre des 10
et 16 ans il est évident et je pense que
c'est pas la peine de créer d'autres
maladies mais non
ma grand-mère les gamins avaient la
guerre ma génération à moi 15 ans tout
d'un coup
ci-dessus le sida arrive il faut vous
pas couché plus basse est un droit à
l'amour et tout ça cette génération de
de quoi vivre le foot mais nous ne
prendrons pas la nommer à chaque
génération d'enfants a connu un
traumatisme et on en est tous revenant
faut ensuite ensuite je pense qu'en tant
qu'adulte on a un devoir moral d'abord
je pense pas que les poilus se soient
sacrifiés pour que le bisso na bisso
barça et franchement ma grand-mère ont
connu naguère la lotto connolly cette
génération a reconnu le masque c'est
bien la pire y ont
droit une trappe dépressif comme
raisonnement ça veut dire que j'ai
prêché dans l'émission
je crois qu'en tant que ruth on a une
responsabilité morale de ne pas faire
peser sur nos jeunes et nos enfants des
injonctions paradoxales la fac moi quand
j'étais à la lgv une part d'ombré c'est
ainsi par terre le tabac fait pour ça qu
on a un enfant jame et à la fac mis tout
ça mais j'ai des ennemis qui est
passé jeudi a passé neuf ans de la son
ton ces corps un enfant on est toxique
mais mes dires d'envoi préserver leur
lui fait rêver mieux que personne meurt
je suis dit on me dira un enfant de
mettre un max n'est pas forcément lui
faire peur ça pour un aller retour et
vous le savez mieux que personne c'est
tout le discours inverse au tour donc
oui il faut travailler l'accompagnement
sur ça mais bien évidemment quand on
aime on a encore affirmé demian
évidemment départ ont bien évidemment qu
on est parent notre responsabilité de
faire en sorte que ça allait mieux et
parce qu'on en finisse avec la colline